okay so the next talk is by vishwas and
we talked about the first polynomial
factorization okay thank you everyone
for showing up so this is joint work
whipped to bunkie my advisor and if your
work awaits I've changed the title
slightly which I think does more justice
to the stuff okay so so the question is
really natural so it's you have a
polynomial in n variables and there is
this slightly different restriction so
instead of having total degree bounded
by D I talked about individual degree
bounded by D it's like it's something
which we usually study so this is
slightly different but it's just a new
parameter so sparsity of a polynomial
which I denote by this norm of F is
actually number of monomials with
nonzero coefficient again let's study
the object so a simple example if you
look at this polynomial sparsity is just
four and the individual degree here is 3
so if individual degrees bounded by D
the sparsity can be as high as D plus
1/2 then so exponential in n but
polynomials which have like Polly and
Polly d-types
monomials we call them sparse polynomial
and it's already natural complexity
mature studied lots and lots of folks ok
so a very natural classic question asked
by wonder Gotham and Kyoto converse are
factors of sparse polynomials sparse so
they looked at this really simple
example which is inspired by a geometric
progression formula it's like if you
look at X I to the D minus 1 then this
thing 1 plus X I plus X I square up to X
a to the D minus 1 is actually a factor
of X a to D minus 1 and if you sort of
boosted by multiplying over all
variables this gives you a sparsity
blower so if you see the sparsity of F
is 2 2 then sparsity of G which is a
factor of F is due to then so you can
see a log B blow and looking at this
they basically are description are
sparse polynomial quasi polynomially
closed and the factoring are all factors
of spots polynomial just
quasi-polynomial parts so they
conjecture this and basically ask this
question what can we do ok so this is a
like rational or complex
so the conductor was that this is
actually true that you can so I will not
say that it's a conjecture it was like
more of a question and a conjecture
together okay so but over finite fields
we can do much more crazy stuff so over
finite field if you have the
characteristic to be P and if you have
this polynomial which is like a power of
a linear form which because of the
through venesection looks like this
sparsity of f is here just n but if you
look at any power of this linear form
where D is less than P this has
completely dense so here you can see an
exponential blow-up in sparsity in terms
of the individual degree so over finite
field there can be exponential blow-up
in terms of individual degree okay so
okay let's ask what are the previous
works known so these are all what how
dense can a factor be as an example can
you tell me a global bounds so what are
all the works on this actually not much
so we know very special cases like B
equal to 1 D equal to 2 which somehow
use the fact that the factor here are
variable disjoint or somewhat variable
different and there was a beautiful
attempt by Duren Oliveira in 2015 where
they sort of claimed that factors of
sparse polymer are actually caused
opposing is polynomial spot with the
beautiful ideas but sort of their fear
their approach was field oblivious and
because of it big field of livius Volkov
it said ok look at this example what do
it this and this simple example somehow
completely so completely messed up this
whole beautiful idea of doing oliveira
but gee divided separate because this is
actually summation X I to the P whatever
finite field FP it looks like this
ah so so we somehow get inspired by
their work and do something and I'll
show what exact thing they showed
afterwards something so but if you
instead of looking at this question are
factors of sparse poll numbers parse if
you look at this more general question
are factors of low complexity polynomial
of low complexity quite a lot of work
was done on this so yes in all these
cases cult often set for VP factors are
indeed close for one set up circuit the
files showed that if you assume small
individual degree they're those for V
and P quite recently that a section a
Sinha Babu chillin renal and no on
Solomon showed that BMP is indeed close
and the factoring and a B peas and
formulas as quasi-polynomial II goes in
the factory so okay in some sense if
circuit class is big enough it's easier
to show that it's close on the factory
because all the computation you require
can be indeed done in that complexity
model that's why this pass polynomial
question is somewhat harder ok good so
let me tell you our results so what we
show is if for all fields this F is s
past then its factors are s to the order
D Square log in sparse so I'll show you
an example where the blow up with s to
the D this is slightly weaker than this
it says s to the D Square log in spot ok
so this is the first non-trivial bound
for any be greater than 2 and I would
like to remark is because I bound is
field oblivious on which I'll tell you
more about this is somewhat tight
because I already shown a exponential
blow-up example where s goes to s to
Daddy
so it's somewhat weak extra disco log in
but has the notion of exponential
blow-up in terms of the individual
degree ok ok so let's go to the proof of
sparse it well it's really simple
so some what do I have to show F is s
pass I have to somehow show that G and H
are also somewhat sparse I have to show
that G and H are like s to the order D
Square log in sparse ok but we in such
form slightly more general result
what we show is suppose GSS pars and I
multiply it instead of looking it as a
factoring problem I look it as a
multiplication problem so G is Esparza
and if I multiply it by arbitrary
polynomial how much can the sparsity
decrease so what we show is instead that
so if G is like s parts and if you
multiply by arbitrary nonzero polynomial
the sparsity of s is actually lower
bounded by s to the 1 by d square login
and this will directly imply our
factored result so in particular you can
interpret this as instead of factoring
question like that there should not be
an overwhelming can now a cancellation
of monomial when you multiply a
polynomial and here I am assuming that
the individual degrees much more general
so if even one factor has small
individual degree we are done or you can
look at that fancy language the ideal of
G where G
ok and the proof goes through this
Newton politics which was discussed in
small details in quite a lot of talks
it's ok
so you have a polynomial and you look at
its exponent vectors so for all a ideas
where a I J's are not equal to 0 which
is called the support of the polynomial
if you look at the exponent vectors and
plot them and look at this convex hull
that is what we call as Newton politics
of a polynomial it's a very small
example suppose you have a simple
polynomial you just draw its exponent
vector and the Newton pointer will look
something like this ok but Newton's
operators have really really nice
properties so the first property is its
well behaved with respect to
multiplication so if you multiply two
polynomials the neutral point ops turns
out to be Minkowski sum this is a
classical fact and the second fact is VP
denotes the number of corner points or
the number of vertices of a polytope
they are somehow and if is a milk so if
you have milk auskey some of then the
vertex are lower bounded by max of the
vertex of in
dividual pollito so i just want to
highlight this is a max not a mean and
this is [ __ ] oh okay
okay so just by staring at these two
things you can get in you can get a
beautiful relation in terms of sparsity
lower bound okay so clearly the sparsity
of a polynomial is bounded by the number
of corner points that is positive
because you will plot it number of
corner points will be mostly less cannot
remove it and since it's a
multiplication by first it's a Minkowski
sum and by the second lemma by the
second fat bounded by max of number of
corner points of individual pollito so
if you notice like a problem which is
completely algebraic it's translated
into a pole problem of discrete geometry
I just have to count the number of
corner points in a polytope to give a
lower bound on sparsity so okay to give
to give a slight intuition so if one can
say that oh so to prove sparsity bound I
have to just look at two facts and
somehow what's the motivation so the
motivation comes out to me if you
multiply two polynomials the main
intuition is if a monomial can be
written in two different ways it can get
cancelled and the Boonen rules which can
only be produced by just one way it will
not get answered so we somehow assume we
someone look at all the monomials which
can be written uniquely which is somehow
captured in this corner point solution
so let me revise our main task g is the
polynomial which is n variate with small
individual degree it is an arbitrary
nonzero polynomial and somehow the
question of lower bounding the sparsity
of F turns out to be just counting the
number of foreigner points in the point
of G okay so this will be the main
technical Emma now and I just want to
remark that this was already known to be
an ollie whether we just somehow build
from that okay so if you have an
arbitrary poly tope then it can have you
there is no dependence between number of
internal punch a number of corner points
why because look at this poly tope it
has slits a few internal points few
corner points but I can always scale it
up I can scale it up and now the number
of interval points are much more
looks like they don't have any relation
but notice we can't do the scaling
because we have this individual degree
bound so in each of the coil each of the
quantities we are bounded by D so we
look we look at something like this sort
of picture we can't go too far away and
instead of counting the number of corner
points in a polytope let's look at the
other question suppose the number of
corner points are T how many internal
points can I have in this poly tope
which is the same just other way of
looking at it so let's say we have T
coordinate points let's see how many
integer points can I put it inside this
poly tope
so okay this is a palette of V T V 1 up
to VTR the number of foreign points and
these blue dots are lattice points by
lattice points because exponent vector
is an integer vector okay so can you
somehow relate these two things can you
somehow say that all these integer
points are maybe some can somehow be
associated with the D of these vectors
as it turns out something very similar
is true so along with each of this
lattice point there is a point very
close to it so epsilon close in the L
infinity sense where epsilon can be
thought of as 1 by 3 so I said these
green points are actually a small
uniform combinations of very few of the
corner points so this was already well
known stated by Berman and has a very
simple proof so suppose you have a bunch
of vector B 1 up to VT and you pick any
point features in the co cork which is
in the context man then there is a so
for all these blue points there is a
Green Point which is very close to it
which is a order D square by L into a
uniform combination what is a uniform
combination so uniform combination of a
bunch of vector is just taking this
average or looking at the centroid if
you want to look geometrically so okay
so yes I said
so so so because each lattice point has
a very closeby neighbor which is a
uniform combination we can associate
each of this lattice point by one of
this uniform combination vector and how
many of these uniform combination
vectors are there so these are T to the
d square login and this directly looks
the sparsity on so somewhat uniform
vector means just an average and there
is a uniform combination vector near
each lattice point so each point there
is a subset for which but how many such
subsets can be if you are just allowed
to take these square long one of them do
utilities for organization what
combination out of all points right yes
yeah that's what this lemma say you
don't have to go to all points just a
few of them because you are working in
this individual degrees
you've been visiting you my point is
even some subset of the vertices at my
branch saying this way you is a subset
of a subset no getting over epsilon
square vectors just which explain this d
square and this Login yes it's the
Birdman proof is just enough you need ok
so ok I'm done with my sparsity bomb
proof so factors of off sparsity as
individual degree dr s 2 d square login
spot every point in the convection of
capital u and you're saying it can be
approximated by a sparse combination of
the points in here
so not here but somehow this interior
points are used because they are quite
far apart and that each can be
associated with at least one unique the
association you're not taking a whole
bunch and also getting into the
deterministic tracking algorithm so let
me give a brief overview about is known
so factoring elbow is given a polynomial
whatever representation you give me you
either give its complete factorization
or tell that it's irreducible cannot be
factorized it's a well studied problem
and has lots and lots of applications so
how do you represent a polynomial white
box a tomato circuit black box a printed
circuit you will need to go in details
so and for all these models we know how
to factorize so these are classical
results and all of them are actually
randomized algorithm and a natural
question was from a long time and even
now can we do randomized these
algorithms
so if you have a black box of a
polynomial you give me a black box of
its factors and so as it turns out the
randomizing this question of polynomial
factorization was actually equivalent to
the problem of D randomizing PID so PID
is a problem given a circuit which is
poly sized poly degree test whether it's
zero or not and cases go party sheriffs
will car showed that theorem the Animas
a PID for VP its class of poly size
politically circuits is actually
equivalent to the randomizing polynomial
factorization for a VP so natural
question is okay we know quite a lot of
P I t's can you do some of the
renovation of polynomials or try this is
both black box and write books if you
give me black box PID I can do black box
purnama factorizations works for both
and okay so one of the main classical
dessert is I can do p 84 sparse polymers
likely eventually men
so can you dear n demise factoring of
sparse polymer this was the 80s and this
does not preserve classes so D
randomizing P IT for path C does not
yield that D randomizing polynomial
factorization let go which I will give a
big overview by so if I go to inside the
KS s details also all these all these
algorithms look like this so there are a
bunch of steps step one require some
randomness are one step to require some
randomness also there lots of step
requiring different types of randomness
and what case is showed that you can
remove all this randomness by going to a
ppit instance so instead of randomness
Arbonne let's hit people them at P 1 and
P 2 and P 3
so it's these polynomials that should be
sparse if I'm looking at the factoring
of F being sparse but these polynomial
if you go into details are actually as
hard as determinant say that like big
gigantic
waitresses and we have no clue how to do
PID for these things so it's really hard
directly going to KS s and time to the
randomized PID and tough on them in
factorization so what we show is we can
actually do this and the time required
is s to reduce to seven log n so if your
D is small enough you can give a
quasi-polynomial bottom here mod of F
means log of the character so Polly in
characteristic or the bit complexity if
you are working over complex so we can
do this sitter mystically just a remark
this logon factors come just because of
sparsity by a bound has this login
factor if we can improve the sparsity
bound this will become a polynomial but
for individual degree constant what
model which i just said more techniques
if it's a finite field
it's poly in the characteristic and if
it's rational or something it's funny in
the bit complexity just the usual sense
to maybe define it over say rationals
can be factored deterministically in
polynomial time multivariate is no
longer known is it it's randomized we
know but domestically it's equivalent to
P idea even over zero characteristic yes
so let's give a generic factoring
algorithm overview there is some
pre-processing a start then there is
this big hammer Hilbert address will
deter them and there's this bunch of GCD
which is done by folding a bunch of
polynomial equations we take a slightly
different the approach is more like
elephant rigor approach we do some
pre-processing again we go around here
but addressability by some hack and then
we do reconstruction of our factors and
then we test our factorization just just
an overview I'll give details so let's
assume for simplicity that our
polynomial is unique in some variable so
this we can assume without loss of
generality and we can do all this thing
deterministically so let's assume it's
Munich in x1 so since our individual
degree steed which is small this D small
so you can do this transformation to
Manik while preserving individual
degrees yes yeah it's all exercise what
can be done just by what was already
known in the literature nothing new idea
okay good so if your F looks like this
its factorization is fairly looks simple
enough it's so if F is munich in x1
etcetera so also munich in x1 and this
gives a really nice thing that there are
at most D factors just because these all
of these factor will have some term of
x1 in it so which is really important in
our analysis so the number of factors
are not too many
okay so let's boil so what is his
abilities with you
Hilbert is usually said if you are in
the randomize world do a random
projection physics from Nvidia to let's
say to variate and irreducible polymers
say roots well what does that mean so it
preserves the factorization pattern
because if g1 is irreducible I will go
to some G 1 tilde being invertible so
somehow going to less number of
variables preserves the factorization
pattern and in deterministic power well
we don't know any but a disability so if
I try to emulate
if I try to do a variable reduction
maybe this can be messed up so instead
of having five factors my factors can be
at most 20 or something so I don't know
and one kind
disability just because the an amazing
is like hitting some big determinants
which we don't know how to do there are
variants basically if you project random
enough irreducible polynomial says in
response line is one variant of it you
can talk about other intensified okay so
we don't know how to do it but let's say
I try to reduce variables somehow and it
get messed up but somehow I can take
care of it what I can do is because how
many factors can it be as I showed
before it they can be at most D many and
D small in my case so I can somehow
brute force it what do I mean by that I
can somehow do a rubbing of all these
pretty things so if I have D many
factors I can go over all possible
clubbing sometimes which is like D to
the D which is not too much in my case
so I can do it for this factorization
pattern now you last but how do you know
which pattern is correct and my answer
to that is I don't need to know and then
I test my factorization I'll go I do my
factoring I'll go for all these patterns
and and then I sum out test my
factorization and give the right answer
so before giving more details I have to
somehow tell you this very nice neat
trick of black box of kite often trigger
so how do you get an Oracle access to
factors so this is a very neat trick if
you so suppose you want to evaluate your
factor at this point alpha comma beta
bar so somehow just project it to this
line which has somehow hidden little
this beta parameter on which you want to
evaluate what is this B is somehow came
from a little bit addressability
it somehow preserves it so this is some
other hack but now if you factorize this
polynomial and if you substitute X equal
to alpha equal to 1 you will exactly get
the evaluation of factor at alpha comma
beta so it's really simple ok so this is
the back black projects and now what do
we have is we somehow after reduction of
variable we have Oracle access to all of
these so we can evaluate G 1 tilde G 2
tilde n and so on and we also know the
club
so we somehow know which of them are
associated to g1 which of them are so G
2 so we have fact we have evaluation of
G 1 G 2 and G 5 and by my factoring
bound by my sparsity bound all of these
polynomials are somewhat sparse since
they are somewhat sparse and we can
reconstruct sparse poll numbers I can i
reconstruct using black box Oracle of
cult open trigger and I essentially get
my factors back from the Oracle so the
remaining step is reconstruct all my
factors and place my factorization what
do you mean by test my factorization so
I have F which I know is parts I knew
the number of factors are not too many
and all of them are individually sparse
and all of them are individual sparse so
this whole system F minus G 1 G 2 up to
G K this system is sparse so I can test
my factorization by doing a simple
events with PID so this just concludes
our factoring Albert hiding few details
how to make Munich but those are all
simple so just to summarize we show if
you have individual degree assumption
then factors is s to the D Square log n
sparse and in if these small enough we
can give a fuzzy polynomial
deterministic algorithm ok so I give
some open problems the first and natural
open problem is can you improve this
parsecity bound so I I gave an example
being s to the D but my bound is to the
d square Logan can you somehow remove it
then you make it X to the D or can you
give me an example where the blow-up is
indeed edge to the d square noggin but
the more interesting question to me is
making it feel specific I somehow
believe that the blow-up should be just
quasi polished should be like s to the
law goes over characteristic 0 fields
and that example of final field just an
anomaly anomaly these things should not
happen
yeah sure so can you make this argument
field-specific can you somehow use that
coefficients do matter so can you make
it feel specific and the other question
is give a factoring algorithm without
the individual degree assumption so
suppose I prove tomorrow that all power
factors of all sports polynomial are in
these parts even if we assume this we
don't know how to reran demise
polynomial factorization for sparse
polynomials so just because we have to
use that Hilbert irritability somewhere
and I don't know if any electric then
just brute forcing overall patterns so
if we don't have this individual degree
assumption even if I assume all factors
of sparse polynomial are sparse
I don't know how to do it and the last
question is actually what my factoring
I'll go gives of what this whole thing's
give is not affecting I'll go for sparse
it actually give a scheme so if you have
the individual degree assumption if you
can reconstruct the factors if you have
both these two things then you can
factorize what do I mean by that so
suppose if you mighty linear ROA P you
have a closure result of factoring you
know how to reconstruct your individual
degree bound this will directly plug
into that and give me a factoring elbow
little mischief train I'll go for that
so for our babies everything works out
except I don't know how to prove I will
be with concert individual degree are
close and refactoring I don't know how
to prove that if someone can prove that
that will directly apply a deterministic
factoring I will go for our abs with
bounded individually so these are three
questions stemming from this but they
are of three different flavor one is if
you are a sparsity fan one if you have a
fan of factoring algorithms and other if
your kind of closure at OSHA rules of
arithmetic circuit class so these are
three different questions which are very
very interesting to me
[Applause]
but that's like some concrete
calculation of the factoring al-kabir to
like do a bunch of steps and that
there's a D to the seven just because of
that it's not essential it's just we did
the calculation to find out what this
exponent was there is nothing unique to
it you can make it D to the fame
absolutely like for general question I
say you know about your polynomials the
the Newton polytope is separated meaning
that any integer point inside belongs to
the support can help you to do the
factoring that again you know that any
integer point in Newton for the top is
actually is in the support question of
structural questions so do you want to
study this Ferris sparsity of factors or
do you want to do so somehow answering
all this question we'll somehow so this
is really an oblivious approach if you
don't care about cancellation what are
the things which can never get cancelled
those are actually captured by corner
points if you tell me anything inside
the polytope I don't know how to use a
solution
[Applause]